we're gonna talk about this year war
from
nine news australia uk plans to sail
through crimean waters again
as russia threatens to bomb on target
now this is all basically because russia
sees crimea and i'll try and very very
simplify everything for those aren't
familiar with the full story
ukraine seems to be going the way of
nato this was several years ago
and that meant russia was going to lose
its only warm water port in the black
sea which is crimea
so they moved in and claimed the people
of crimea voted to join russia
well apparently the people of ukraine
don't believe that's the case and i know
a lot of people in ukraine and i know
people
who have family and friends in crimea
say it's also not the case they want to
join russia
there's not much you can do when you're
being occupied by a military and they
have no way to defend themselves
well now you have the uk who doesn't
recognize this
running along the coastline and russia
is basically dropping bombs and firing
warning shots and threatening
we will bomb you if this is the case so
let me just read a little bit they say
russia annexed crimea from ukraine after
a military intervention in the region in
2014.
russia said the uk's hms defender went
three kilometers inside what described
as its territory off of cape what does
it say violent in crimea
just before noon on wednesday a nation's
territorial waters extend 12 nautical
miles
off from its coastline any foreign
warship going past that limit
would need permission of the country to
do so with a few exceptions
prime minister boris johnson and defense
secretary ben wallace both backed the
assertion we don't recognize the russian
annexation of crime yet it was illegal
these are ukrainian waters and it was
entirely right
to use them to go from a to b he denied
that uk russian relations right historic
low
noting that i can remember times in my
own lifetime when things have been far
worse
the important point is that we don't
recognize the russian annexation of
crimea
this part of sovereign this is part of
cyber and ukrainian territory mr johnson
told reporters on thursday during a
visit
to an army barracks in england this is a
game of chicken
you know who do you think's got the the
the cajones to
make that move well speaking of the
cojones like where did the uk
get the call right from like like the
fact that they're like of all the things
that they have going on
in the uk with brexit and and trying to
sort out their economy
like where are they like peak hacking
around like how did they come to the
table with this
actually it's kind of a sad thing to
think about because i
did this threat on the founding fathers
uh earlier how i was like that this the
people who signed the declaration of
independence
knew that they were declaring war on the
most powerful military the world had
ever seen
and they thought they were going to lose
many many did and it was some say it was
only because of french intervention that
we actually were able to win
the french of course had an interest in
defeating the british uh it's funny that
that narrative of the british being so
powerful
and now it's like wow where did britain
get the balls to go up against russia
oh man that's it but what but seriously
like like what do they get out of this
ukrainian situation and why are they i
mean
they know they don't have a strong ally
in the us anymore in terms of being able
to support so like why are they out
there like
we're gonna be you know going up against
russia and russia's like we must break
you
how did that sort of all i don't know
you know it's interesting because the
the big narrative for a long time was
that
ukraine was had there's a natural gas
monopoly through the gazprom
you know company russia and it's running
through ukraine so the u.s wanted the
qatar turkey pipeline to go up through
syria and turkey and then into
the you know into um the eu to offset
their monopoly and lower prices
but syria said no and then war breaks
out and it's all chaos and conflict and
then joe biden's like
i'm going to improve this uh was it
nordstrom 2
where they're building another pipeline
and biden's like we're going to allow
this
so it's really confusing to me when
you're trying to follow through this
this history
and the news about why we're currently
entering this level of conflict
i mean obviously we are allies with the
uk and this is a lot a lot about nato
but why allow russia to build another
pipeline
through you know uh it's like just north
of europe along the along the coast
why allow that but then taunt them and
play these games
and be upset about ukraine it seems
something's broken right now we're
trying to
frame it as if we did nothing wrong and
we were we got attacked so we're the
ones that are
they're just in the situation because i
mean but
the truth is it's moronic to poke the
beast regardless i
i don't know man history will tell you
know and i'm a money person so i'm like
trying to follow the pipeline and follow
the money and going okay like who's
benefiting where
and where are the dollars flowing
because at the end of the day that
on one side or the other that's what
this has got to be all about either
it's about somebody getting money or
someone trying to bleed more money out
of the u.s
i think i think the interest in this
this story may just
be saber-rattling there have been like
russian flybys before
there have been like russia you know
their their planes entering like u.s
airspace kim jong-un got to too much uh
too much journalistic space for all of
his little things so they had to kind of
step up and go no we're bad guys too
don't forget about us but these things
happen and
usually like we don't see much so i'm
wondering if it's
people are interested in this simply
because of the idea of like the fourth
turning i mean i'll say this is one of
the reasons i'm interested in seeing
this news because it sounds like
the uk and russia are playing a game of
chicken and of course if that comes to
blows
we're involved um there's a fear that
we're in this crisis period where
there's going to be a major
war china of course is saying we'll work
with russia to counter attack
so you know i can't remember what was it
bannon who was talking about this
they were saying that you know russia
should not be aligned with china but
we've effectively
forced that on them especially when the
democratic party has been repeatedly
just bash russia
bashing non-stop so russia's you know
pushed back saying okay fine it's us
against you
now they work with china but again this
could just be
words it could be meaningless russia
could just be shaking their fist from
the shoreline while the uk passes by
nothing ever happens but it's a great is
a great way to put the
us in a financial and a national pickle
isn't it
especially when you don't have sort of
strength um at the top leadership
because what is it that we can't afford
more than anything else
it's certainly another war and so from a
dollar
standpoint as well from a national
standpoint um the split in terms of
people who would be
foreign against that you know we don't
need that right now and
certainly if you're savvy if you're in
in russia and you're in china
you're aware that we don't need that
right now there's also
wokeness right this whole critical race
theory battle and it subsets
tearing at the core of the united states
and now we see
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff just being like outright like
what's wrong with being woke i take
offense to that i want to understand
white rage and it's like oh geez
i can only imagine that russia and china
are well aware of the rift in the us
and this is what worries me if the uk
gets bold and says we're gonna drive our
boats by
russia might be like hey if we bomb them
right now they can't do anything about
it the us is fractured
their military's gone woke so is that i
don't know what do you think we
is that is that a big risk or am i
overthinking things no i think it's a
it's a huge risk and i think we need to
be talking to our little friends in
britain and telling them to settle down
a little bit
because like you said it's sort of moral
hazard right they're the ones who are
going to
to poke the beast as you said but they
aren't the ones that are going to suffer
most of the repercussions it's going to
fall back on us so
you know maybe they might just want to
slow their role a little bit that scares
me though
because you know we saw china saying
that the us is not in a position of
strength
if the reality is we do have to be like
uk please don't don't bother crimea we
know russia stole it but
we can't do it now now is not a good
time maybe come back to us in a couple
years
man i feel like i feel like the u.s is
in trouble the whole
the whole world is in trouble it's a
house of cards and if there's a global
war it's i mean that's
could set us back 10 000 years i mean we
did did you see what china was saying
about kovid
and lab leak they were like if you
investigate the origins
we need it was china state media
speaking to themselves saying we need to
up production of nuclear weapons
to send a shiver down the spines of the
american elites so you got like
nuclear sable writing russia apparently
they issued a statement saying
that their official response to any war
including conventional warfare like if
some missiles go flying they'll launch
nukes
now will they really i don't think so
they're like we'll respond to aggression
but we will use nukes
i think a lot of this could just be like
fist shaking from the shoreline
you know testing the waters that could
be it too
yeah but maybe the uk warship is just
sailing by and then russia is like
uk and that's all that really happens
you know yeah i wonder if there's a
crypto tie in here as we we've
kind of offline talked about you know
china's role in crypto and digital
currency and obviously they're trying to
become
the world's reserve currency and what a
better way to
you know continue the the great work
that the federal reserve has done in
devaluing the dollar
then trying to bring us into another war
that we need to print a bunch of money
for that we can't afford
you know not to like throw out random
conspiracy theories here but just again
trying to kind of connect
things that potentially could happen
there could be a tie-in with that
well i think i think it all is there's i
mean first of all we probably don't even
realize how much is connected to all of
this
yeah we might be looking over here at
this you know uk
the hms defender right and we're like
wow what a story
and we might not even know that an
actual
you know conflict with actual live fire
happened somewhere else you know what i
mean like
the news that comes out for instance the
gulf of tonkin incident which brought us
into uh vietnam
we didn't actually know the full details
for decades we just got some reports
later on i just found out the uss
maine was like a false flag that got us
involved in the spanish-american war
to liberate cuba liberated from uh the
spanish empire it was just it blew up
no one knew why and then william randall
first started printing articles that
were like remember the main remember the
main and everyone went to war with cute
with
with uh okay so if we're talking about
like things that are distractions so
then we had all of these
cyber attacks that happened in the u.s
on the pipeline on the meat plants and
stuff
and it's sort of planting the seeds oh
russia is doing these things russia is
doing these things now we've got this
conflict with russia
so yeah we actually have this thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast
irl monday through friday at 8pm where
you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you